hey everybody Doug Walker here uh no
nostalgia Creek this week the reason
being my vacation and the reason we
decided to pick this week to do the
vacation is because this would allow us
to tie in to another review we want to
do on a movie being released but you'll
never guess what it is uh but yeah you
can probably catch on but yeah I just
got back from a convention here and I
didn't want you guys to feel like oh you
know why something so this is something
uh these are my top seven favorite anime
movies the reason why it's seven and not
ten or eleven is because uh
actually haven't seen enough to make
this list like you know as I'm not just
talking about like movies like oh that's
good I like that I what like I love
these movies cuz there are some anime
movies they're just so phenomenal and so
incredible uh and not to say a bunch of
these others aren't but these really
hold a special place for me and they're
just really these amazing films that
just really really stick in my heart and
you know and I see a lot of anime shows
as well that are just as good but we're
just sticking to movies today and before
I talk about that I should make a few
things clear
um ghost in the shell' is not on here
and the reason for that is I saw it when
I was very young and I didn't get it
I was like super super young agent I
didn't follow it I didn't follow what's
going on so I need to re-watch that
movie and see if it's a tree as good as
everybody says it is I'm sure it is but
that's one of the reasons it's not on
here and then I have not seen the girl
who slept through time or summer Wars
those are ones that everybody says are
like some of the best ones I have not
seen them so at some point I'll watch
all those three films and get back to
you about what I think about them you
know like either a video or like my
facebook or something like that and yeah
but these are the films that I
absolutely adore like these kind of
almost helped shape me in a sense and
just when I think of really great anime
films like these are the ones that come
into my mind not just for the technicals
and the animation but for what great
stories and great characters there so
let's get going number seven is
millennium actress uh this is a very I
haven't seen a film really
like this there's a lot of elements
about it that are very abstract very
dreamlike and it's kind of hard to
explain it's both very easy and very
hard to explain it's a it's a film crew
that's going in to interview this
actress that's had this amazing life
that's banned over years and years and
she's very old now and they're just sort
of getting her life story up but it's
more than that it's most movies you know
they would do this and they would ask
the questions and then she would just
tell the story and they cut to
flashbacks and they tell it from
beginning to end and you know that'd be
about it and he would be a good life
story uh this one is like it's almost
like the memories that she has are
blended together with the performances
that she did and the movies that she did
so in her old age she's kind of
confusing the two and because both the
movies and her life are so interesting
the filmmakers kind of get into a two
and it kind of creates this strange kind
of world of memory and subconscious and
uh things you enjoy things you feared uh
things tied in with your worth things
tied in with your life and they all kind
of come together in this hodgepodge and
you have to just kind of not even figure
out what's real and what's not but just
kind of accept it like this is just what
her mind is now and it's such an
intriguing journey that the filmmakers
get sucked into it as well like they're
in the memories with her and I adore
that idea I just think anything about
you know sort of the subconscious and
bringing the conscious conscious or vice
versa uh I think it's just so intriguing
and I think with an anime to do that
well this director does a lot of stuff
like that he also do a perfect blue and
paranoia agent so he really likes kind
of dealing with this stuff you did
paprika as well which is about dreams uh
and I really think this is kind of like
his masterwork with that because it is
not again it's not spoon fit to you it's
not made easy and whilst watching this
film I can
thing like oh I got this figured out now
I'm I know what's going on and what's
what and and you don't and you're not
really supposed to it's supposed to sort
of offer you these choices that you can
maybe say oh maybe that happened or
maybe you think this but it's left open
but the the choices they make to
actually show you in terms of like who
she is and her identity and her past and
and where it ties in to the movie and
how how intertwined they really are I
think are very clever and I think that's
what separates it from the film where
you just go it's all abstract you're not
supposed to know what it means or do you
know what it means here's my
interpretation because those kind of
films I mean those kind of films are
wonderful too if done well and it's hard
to say what makes them dumb well what
makes them done poorly you know David
Lynch usually doesn't well tarsem
usually does not so it's one of those
things where I feel this film really
kind of challenges you you know it
doesn't just say come on in and because
we're an animated film we're gonna make
this very easy for you to follow and
visually interesting uh you know just a
nice little eye candy for you in a
simple story they really really
challenged you with it and I just adore
the way it's done and this guy's done a
lot of great work and you know in my
opinion this is his absolute best or at
least my personal favorite so definitely
go check it out the oven yet number six
is the wind rises and no they're not all
going to be a Miyazaki films on this
though there are a couple more but I
love this film when it first came out
and I loved it now as someone who really
really loves his work even to a point
where he's making a video i's day off
this is a kind of film i really identify
with and it's something where there's a
bit of controversy around it I've
definitely heard people talk about if
you don't know this is a true story
about the man who built the the fighter
planes that attacked Pearl Harbor uh but
his big thing was that he just wanted to
create he wanted to change thing he
wanted to change the world
old and he was a you know he was kind of
as aviator he made these planes and they
were these incredible designs they just
happen to be used for the wrong purpose
but he didn't really know to some extent
even care that much what they were used
for he just wanted to innovate he want
to create and that's what this film
focuses on and it does show very clearly
at the end even him not knowing if he
made the right choice and I think
there's something - I feel like
entertainers now especially I actually
probably not made probably always uh
there's always this sense that that's
what they want to do they want to
entertain they want to act they want to
direct they want to write they want to
sing they want to do all these things or
just one of these things something very
simple and then when you kind of get
into the technicals of it some people
can pull it off okay uh some don't they
get sucked into making these wrong
choices that they don't think are gonna
affect anything or maybe they're naive
and wrong choices they're just they're
just choices that are taken by the mass
public or something and having a bigger
effect than they realize and I think it
kind of sounds like Miyazaki's kind of
that person in many respects like he
just loves making things he loves
creating things and the technicals of it
yeah he's good the technicals - I don't
know I mean like Walt Disney was good
the technicals as well there's so many
people that can do soar both the
artistic and the business side but
there's a lot of people they're only
business I a lot of people they're only
the artistic I'm very much
only the artistic I'm terrible at
business so I don't handle that end but
it's one of those things where I've seen
a lot of people you know just totally
thrive on it you know and they let
someone else do it it turns out great
I'd seen other people let someone else
take it over and it just completely
crashes and burns so I feel like this is
one of those films where it's about the
passion very much it's about the
inspiration it's about kind of lack of a
better term listening to your dreams
because that's literally what he does in
this he goes to bed and he
he listens to kinda what his dreams are
telling him cuz like his heroes and his
subconscious or giving him advice and
showing what he could be and again even
at the very end there's kind of this
little bit of you know talking to his
heroes like you know man what what have
we done was this a good thing or a bad
thing that we did and I'm glad it's
touch devise not completely ignored but
that's clearly not the focus the focus
is that drive that can push a person and
just how much it can overcome and how
far it can push you in both the best way
and in some respects the worst way but
they're mainly focusing on the positive
they're focusing on the innovation and
the hard work and determination that
this guy has and as someone that also
creates a lot of content and is so
blessed to be doing this for a living
I really identify with it I just really
think the the passion and the love of
what he does he just let that kind of
become his life and that just seems
really inspiring um even though we know
what it ultimately results in but it's
still it's a fascinating film and I
really enjoy it and it's I think close
to three hours and when we saw it it
wasn't till the very end that was just
like our butts are starting to feel a
little sore here but by the time it was
over like we couldn't believe that was
three hours we thought maybe two
possibly two and a half but then we
looked at the watch it's like Olli Crab
cuz it just went by it was just so
entertaining and so enjoyable and the
characters were so likeable uh the only
thing I didn't know about was the
romance that seemed very Disney that
almost seemed like you know don'twe
someone for three days but I also don't
know about culture I don't know about
time period I don't know if this is kind
of how it worked or is that kind of the
charm of it - like it was young puppy
love and they didn't know any better or
just happen to work out or it didn't
it's it's one of those things where I
don't know I can't question the movie a
little bit on that
um but everything else in the film I
just think is so well done and you can
just see Miyazaki stamp all over it not
just in the animation but in the
absolute love of creating something so
definitely one of my favorites right
there
number five is grave of the fireflies
it's surprisingly not number one oh how
people put his number one or number two
but no this one's a little lower not not
any Fault in the film at all it's a it's
a spectacular film it's more just I kind
of like these others a little better and
you know again they just kind of
connected with me a little bit more but
this film again I was talking about
movies that really challenge you in this
film like especially when I saw it
really challenged me I really thought I
was gonna get like a Saving Private Ryan
or a platoon just war is hell and and
and those kind of films are fine and are
very effective but that's not what this
was this is a very much a semi inspired
true story about a young man as a little
sister maybe oh man really a boy I mean
he's not that old in this and he it's
during World War Two again somehow it
all ties together I guess after the last
one the war almost doesn't matter in it
it's kind of not the focus it could kind
of be any tragic event it could be a
tsunami it could be an earthquake it
could be you know just about anything uh
makes its impact you know on these main
characters and it's about him and his
little sister trying to live alone and
kind of the sin of pride and how it can
really really just push you so far even
if you think you're doing it for a good
cause are you doing it for the best
it really can do this amazing damage um
but and I'm not giving anything away
because it literally starts off showing
that they're dead so that's not a
spoiler they literally the first minute
of the film it's like they're dead so
that that's not giving anything away but
it's showing kind of what led up to it
uh kind of the love between these two
and how much they you know they really
do they really are you know a family but
also kind of the the pain they're
putting each other through I mean
especially to the little sister I mean
the boy to the little sister um and I
when I saw it I wasn't ready to get it
because I think I was his age you know I
was about like maybe 15
seeing something like that I was not
ready to understand what the film was
trying to tell me but when I see it
years later it's something where now I
understand at age a little better and I
think part of the film is saying that
you know there is this pride issue when
you're often that age and I think I was
going through that as well so I wasn't
ready to catch on but now as an adult I
do catch on and it is a very tough film
to watch now because of it especially I
think it's very clever you start off
knowing what's going to happen to the
main characters at the very beginning
usually that that would give a lot away
but I think knowing that and watching
these characters and knowing they're
like they're fine they're just you know
perfect little kids they're just this
it's just kind of this age and it's kind
of you know this environment pushing
this pride to go as far as it is and I
guess you could say it's a cautionary
tale or even like an anti-war film but
it's it just kind of feels like here's
some stuff that happened here's the
effects that it had on them and whether
you want to kind of get whatever message
you get out of it you can that's fine it
more felt to me like it just kind of
wanted to show these two lives that you
know we're kind of these two beautiful
lives but they didn't always make the
right choices and didn't always go the
right direction and it's not something
where it's like oh this person's awful
this is just a terrible terrible
character it's very much that I think
especially uh especially the Japanese I
think within many America it's just
about anyone really I mean I don't we
don't even know if it's a cultural thing
uh there are just some people that can
push themselves too too far beyond what
they're capable of and we always say
that's great to push yourself beyond
what you're capable of and in many
respects it is but where we have seen
stories where people can push themselves
to death or make choices where they
should have backed off they should have
dropped the sword they should have been
humble they should have said okay accept
defeat there's a really great scene in
here where they find out that they've
lost the war and the boy just can't
accept that
and that really says a lot about him I
think that says so much about the
character because he isn't just I mean
it's understandable to be upset but he
isn't proud that the suffering is done
and that the people you know can now
sort of breathe again and he doesn't
have to hide and so I mean it's like he
just can't believe they lost I mean that
incredible dishonor that is there so I
think it's something where you kind of
see that aid very much but the the
passion of that age but also the
downside of where that passion can lead
and who it can really damage so it's but
you also see like again but the love of
that family and the love of that brother
and sister and how much even though this
is so hard what they're going through I
mean they're really trying to help each
other out and you really feel the love
between them so it's it's a again a very
challenging film and I adore it for that
it just gets better and better every
single time I see it uh so yeah that's
definitely what I'm anytime I show it to
an adult it sort of takes him a bit but
they're like wow okay like that
now they let that sit that's really good
and we show to a younger person they
often react like I do they did they
don't know what to think of it I think
that's good I think that's a a very
healthy not to necessarily know how to
react to this film and this idea um but
I think it's still good to show at that
young age just to kind of you know drop
these ideas in there even that's not
fully being comprehended you know just
something where it's in there it's
always kind of rattling around so that
years later you can look back and go oh
that's what that was or me that was kind
of helping develop me more than then I
realized so definitely a very very
powerful film number four is wolf
children and if you know anyone with
kids or are someone with kids this is a
good movie to see not that as an
instructional guide or anything like
that it's just more again kindly grave
of the fireflies just showing this
experience and it's technically it's
technically like a supernatural
experience it's technically a werewolf
movie but it doesn't play like that at
all the set up is at
this woman uh falls in love with his
young man who's a half guy half wolf I
can turn into a wolf uh they have a good
night together and she turns out to be
pregnant and they have two kids he dies
actually tied into kind of like his
instinct as a wolf he this leads to his
death
so she's left alone to raise these
half-human half wolf children who can
you know one minute look like kids
another minute look like wolves very
much like wolves rain
um and that's about it it's just her
raising these kids and her life raising
these kids with this very distinct
strange thing that she doesn't
understand because apparently it's never
really happened before at least not that
she knows of uh and trying to figure out
what's right what's wrong what's the
best way what's the worst way and seeing
them develop and good God so many things
with that idea and I feel like it just
takes advantage of everything that can
with that idea it's not an action film
it's not uh you know trying to show off
you know any cool fighting scenes or
anything like that or any cool
transformations it's very much about
trying to raise kids and in this case
you know it's kids that have this see
here's why I love it too you can't
really say disability you can't really
say anything's wrong or right it's just
they're different and it's trying to
utilize those differences to how it's
going to help them best and how it's
going to help shape and discover their
identity and I think what makes that so
good in this film and so surprising
again without giving away too much is
that there's a very strong shift in the
kids like as they grow up you kind of
see them growing up in most films when
you see kids growing up they're sort of
set up their characteristics are set up
very very young and then they just kind
of let them expand as they get older and
yeah you think it's how growing up works
but this film is very clever in that it
kind of finds this one moment to
suddenly
this very strong shift like this
incident happens to one of the kids and
it very quickly kind of transforms them
a little bit but you see it you see very
slowly how the transformation sort of
leaves an impact on the kid and the rest
of the family and just that slow kind of
change and what the kid is becoming and
through both physically and in identity
and it was very much you know majority
of the time you know the disc it was
this way this kid was that way and as
what we were getting and then the serve
change happens and people forget that
happens a lot with kids especially when
they're hitting like their teen years
there's sort of this very strong change
that happens some don't some stay very
similar they just you know it gets
smarter or add a few things take away a
few things but with some there can be
just this super out of nowhere change
that happens and I never see that in
movies I always sort of see you see
where everything kinda comes from it's
this gradual of evolving of the
characters of the kid growing up and
stuff like that but still kind of the
same character you know just now they
have to grow up and be tougher or
understand responsibility and that's
fine that's all good and there's many
kids who grow up that way but we all
know there's those kids who when they
grow old or hit TEENhood or college or
whatever it's like wow something changed
like something just really snapped and
made them very very different and I
think this film is so clever to catch on
that and to show again where it leads
and where it goes and it's very much the
journey of not just the kids but the
mother as well and you just you feel the
stress in this movie of just raising
these kids I think anyone that's raising
kids particularly if you're raising them
on your own I mean you can just see the
stress of this film and just how
hair-pulling it is but you also see the
beautiful side and the incredible side
and just how phenomenal these children
can be in a phenomenal the mother can be
and it really is just kind of a
coming-of-age story you know and it's
it's just so well done and it's kind of
very low-key I'm a can have very
aggressive even scary moments but it's
the most part just watching this family
develop and it's just yeah it's so good
it's one of the more recent ones I well
maybe I just thought recently but I I
saw it's like a year ago so I probably
came out a few years before that but
yeah the animation is beautiful and the
story is beautiful and the characters
are wonderful and I loved watching them
develop and it is just such a good good
flick if you haven't seen it definitely
definitely check it out
number three is Akira or a kid I I never
know the pronunciation because I've seen
several dubs of this movie and a lot of
them pronounce it differently uh I still
have a soft spot for what I call the
Ninja Turtle dub where half the
characters sound like the Ninja Turtles
and the general sounds like Georgie
Scott um and it's kind of lame and silly
but there's also kind of this passion to
it it's like the first one I saw so
vedantam getting sidetracked uh so it's
strange I'm pulling this one so high
after these like really emotional
stories because uh this is not a
particularly emotional story not that
there's no motion in there there is and
and it's done very visually in stuff but
it's a it's very much an action film
it's a sci-fi film it's uh it's huge
gigantic its violent its gory
it's got weird creatures in it and we're
mutating things that crush people and
just people by the bucketloads die in
cities being destroyed and blown up and
stuff like that kind of what you think
of when you think of like a traditional
anime and I can't fully explain why I
love it so my well okay all that stuff's
great but why do I love it more than
these uh very emotional human stories um
and I don't know I don't want to say
it's just the animation I don't think
that's it even though the animation is
phenomenal it's done by one of like my
top three or four favorite animation
studios where TMS I think is what's
called or TSM I'm forgetting it I'll
just look it up look up who did Akira
yeah but they're the same people that
did like uh anime
Animaniacs and Tiny Toons and Peter Pan
the Pirates and they're still working
and they did Little Nemo in Slumberland
which is not a very good movie but the
animation is great uh there is something
about their style
I just adore and I especially adored it
in like Tiny Toons and at manias because
it was always the best animation they
had some good animation out there but
that was always the best that's the one
where you could like freeze the frame
when somebody gets hit and you would see
like just one frame of this hilarious
drawing at the impact and then the next
frame they're just gone or flat or
something like that and that's a kind
thing they would do they don't have just
these amazing details in just these one
frames in like all this action all this
craziness going on that you would just
pause and be like look at that what a
phenomenal just they snuck that in they
snuck in that little bits go stay in the
back of your head you don't even know
it's having this incredible impact on
the motion everything but it is it's
like that one frame that's always snuck
in there and phenomenal work but that's
kind of animation it's in here but
that's not the only thing I think
there's something about uh serve this
aggressive world that it created it's
kind of this mystery going on as well it
very much feels to me like this is kind
of like the anime 2001 uh and what I
mean by that is definitely not the style
or tone because again mm what doesn't
have much action sequences or anything
like that they don't have many bikers
but sort of the same idea that like
there's sort of this big leap in
evolution or change or whatever you want
to call it and just the impact is heavy
the way the human psyche has an impact
on this giant change what's going to
mean like for the world you know just
this kid gets this incredible power and
what does that mean just a human boy
what's that gonna amount to what impact
is that going to have how are we as a
species going to react to that boy what
are we gonna do to him um adjust the
consequences of that but there's also
other kids that have this power in the
past and how it all kind of ties to get
other and it's just I don't know it's
aggressive and it's violent but it's
intriguing
maybe that's the word it's an intriguing
movie every time I see it I'm just
always sucked into these characters I
always kind of feel like I'm watching
for a first time again every single time
I put it on there's never like oh I know
what's gonna happen or I've seen this
scene a million times or whatever and
even if I have it always feels like I'm
watching it for a first time I always
knows either with the animation or the
character or something in the story uh
something I even noticed before and it's
just it's a fascinating movie and it
just really kind of sucks you in um and
I don't know it's hard to figure out
what else to say about it's just this
it's beautifully surreal it has a lot of
stuff I love like I love Terry Gilliam
movies so there's like a lot of these
weird creatures in there but I also love
kind of these great action films there's
a lot of great action and science
fiction it's kind of like this
hodgepodge of a lot of the things that I
really like it probably has big part to
do with it too it's just all these
really really cool scenes I like that
you can have a movie where there's laser
beams and people riding motorcycles
going on shooting but you can have a
scene where these little teddy bears are
going by and this giant monster teddy
bear comes out and they try to smash
each other and then he's in like a river
of milk and these giant Legos are kind
of like it goes really surreal and weird
too and I just adore that so uh yeah
it's just it's a great combination of
pretty much everything I love in a lot
of movies and in a lot of animation so I
love and I find it just so very very
interesting number two is the exact
opposite of that you can't get more
opposite it's Kiki's Delivery Service uh
a lot of people talk about my neighbor
totoro being like their favorite
Miyazaki film or their favorite Miyazaki
children's film and I totally I get it
that's fine I enjoy it as well
Kiki's mine there is something about
this idea there something about the
animation there's something about the
environment that is just so relaxing and
so beautiful and so simple
and I just love seeing what happens is
this little witch that just leaves home
finds this town goes tries to live her
life that's it that's the story and I
love them there are so many films that
feel they had to put a villain in or
they had to put you know the certain
type of conflict and that we've seen a
million times or like a bully or a race
or some sort of big event and you know
life is enough you know it just
sometimes living your life is so
challenging and so crazy that that's all
you really need just good characters
working off of each other and
discovering things and growing up and
evolving and I think this film just does
that so well and they make the
characters so likeable especially Kiki
she's just so friggin adorable and I
just always want to know what she's
gonna do who she's gonna come across you
know she comes across at artists in the
woods she comes across that geeky kid
that makes these little flying bicycles
and stuff and it's just it's just a life
of somebody that happens to have this
very strange thing that she's a witch
and the world accepts that she's a witch
how many movies have that it's always
old we don't know what this is a way to
keep it a secret why
this is totally a movie that's like know
they exist let's embrace it let's figure
out what it would be like if the world
really had this and got over you know
whatever the initial shock or whatever
if there even is one we don't know that
really the past of this me there's just
always been witches but it's something
where there's this you know person's not
like everybody else
but there's a group of them and people
understand it you know some people are
still gonna sort of look at her a little
differently but they know who she is
they know what she is and it's just her
interaction with everybody and it's just
her flying this little broom the flying
scenes are amazing it always feels like
you're really flying with her and
there's no CG in it at all there's not
even really that many like moving shots
or anything like this just something
about the angles that they get honestly
just an anime in general III don't know
how they figured it out but there's
something about when they do flight in a
mage and really when they do almost
anything action-oriented
animation or motion it really feels like
it's moving and this is long before CG I
would actually almost even argue that
even though CG is wonderful in many
animes uh there's something about the
still shots and the angles they had to
get they had to be a little bit more
clever and they had to get that precise
angle and the precise shadows where it
really looks like what's happening is
happening like when there's an explosion
and they get high up you'll see like a
smoke come out and you'll see like the
shadow of the smoke and you'll see a
sort of reflect off of a bush or a wall
or you know whatever a window and
there's something about that that those
simple little things that somehow it
feels much more real in like those still
shots so even though there's not many
explosions in it at all there's a
blitzing at the end which actually I'm
not the biggest fan of but I guess you
need some sort of climax um but just
watching this kid live her life and just
discover things and just fly around make
these deliveries just make people happy
who she comes across but she's trying to
figure out herself how to be happy and
you know she goes through this you know
little sickness and stuff and then she
has to kind of get her powers back
there's a scene it for some reason it
makes me so emotional I'm just like
goddammit whenever I see this scene uh
and I'll give it away a little bit I
mean you should see his movie if you
haven't but it does it's not a huge like
story development or anything but she's
supposed to deliver like this something
that like this little girl Graham or
something is made it's this dish that
she puts a lot of effort into every
single one of her birthdays and she has
someone deliver it but something went
wrong or or she lost the dish or
something so Kiki helps this grandma
this delightful grandma just the nicest
old lady make another one she's working
so hard we can't miss her birthday we
can't miss her birthday and so she gets
this dish made and they wrap it up and
she flies it over and there's a little
girl's birthday party and she kind of
gives Kiki this look at oh who are you
and she's like oh I have this delivery
you know the this food that your grandma
made she's like oh god I really hate
these things all right I'll sign for it
and she takes it like oh man
never ever like these and she slams the
door and like the flight bag key he's
just flying back it's raining she just
kind of has her head down she just
collapses on the bed never talks about
it never gets a dress never brought up
again but by god I get so pissed off I
get so pissed off whenever that little
bitch just looks at that thing it's like
oh I hate these things I'm like fuck you
you little brat that just so gets me
emotional and it's like this movie is
getting me invested in what a little
girl thinks of this dish that our
grandma makes how does it do that like
it just so lures you into this very
relaxed calm state that you're suddenly
getting really invested in these tiny
little emotions that while small still
mean quite a bit and they can really
have an impact I think by not bringing
it back again by not bringing back that
grandma character or the little girl or
you know Kiki never even says out loud
the impact it has on her they just kind
of show visually because it's not like
we're gonna put all our attention on
this the movie knows it's a small moment
but it still has an effect and I love a
film that can just find those small
moments and they can emphasize how
important they are because they're
always gonna happen we're always going
to have a million small moments in our
lives but we're not always realizing
they're having the impact that we
realize they're having or maybe the
Internet is emphasizing even more of
those small moments or maybe we're
obsessing over those small moments but
regardless uh it's something where it's
very much showing one of these small
moments and just letting it kind of sit
with you and it's it's just nothing but
feds that's my phone ringing sorry um uh
ants in the other room but yeah I just
think those small moments just means so
much and I adore how much how much love
how much passion how much creativity and
how much patience this film has that it
doesn't go to over-the-top and too crazy
that they keep it very very small and
very quiet
um but still so magical somehow it makes
all the little things that she does just
the little flying around scenes like she
almost bumps into a building if she just
got pushes it away with her
Legg I mean those little touches just
feel so real and so genuine and I just
adore it I just adore this movie if you
haven't seen it definitely check it out
I know it's not for everyone for a lot
of people might be too slow or too
boring but I just think it's amazing and
I love watching it anytime
number one is spirited away some of you
already know that do I even need to
explain this is so many people's like
favorite animes and yeah it's mine too
uh when I saw the trailer for it it
looked amazing when I saw the movie it
came through all the way I mean just
every scene it's just so great uh it's
very much
you know it's it's very much Alice in
Wonderland it's very much a character
character goes into strange world and
trying to figure out the strange world
and you know a little bit of a lesson a
little bit of life lessons going on but
it's mostly just her interacting with
these strange creatures and these
strange people and it's big and it's
scary and it's intimidating but it's
through all of that they find the charm
they find the intrigue they find the
imagination these are the films that we
grew up with in the 80s as kids like the
return to us or the secret of NIMS
the ones we're not seeing a ton of now
and I can't say you know kids films now
are awful particularly the animated ones
I mean where we're getting really really
good stuff and with very very adult
things in it but yeah there's something
about that element of we just want to
scare the shit out of you but also
fascinate you and take you in a world of
imagination I mean that just was really
big in the 80s and we're just not
getting that much of anymore and I'm
sure you know why I mean it's like
people saying how we don't wanna scare
our kids but we do get some we
definitely still get some in there and
they sneak in these scary little scenes
and kids films but this is just one big
scary scene pretty much for little kids
it's technically a children's movie but
it's so imaginative and it's so
intriguing it's so creative uh and the
characters are
so weird and so odd but the main one is
just so simple and so so likable and
what kind of a brat she is but also kind
of how innocent and afraid she is a kind
of how whiny she is and this is one of
those films were it's just it'd be so it
could so easily go awry but they don't
they just keep the focus on what's
interesting in the movie and that's this
little girl's interaction with all these
strange things and it takes the time to
be scary but it also takes the time to
be you know very calm very quiet very
beautiful one of my favorite scenes in
all film just when the train is taking
the kid - you know - just across the
really the ocean I guess since the rain
came down and it's just this train on
water and these little ghosts and
strange creatures getting on and getting
off and it's just quiet nothing is said
they're just sitting there and the
lighting is amazing and it's just mood
it's just this incredible mood
throughout the whole thing and that's
what I get out of this movie I get this
mood I get these feelings uh I always
say like you know my when people ask you
know like people know I have a really
bad memory and they're always like you
know do you remember specifics about
what happened in the past I said no but
I remember how I feel about them and
maybe that's why I really relate to
these films that don't always have to
explain everything or a super super
talkie they can just kind of let the
experience sit with you they can just
kind of let the feeling sink in you know
that and it doesn't always have to be
the feelings of a story can be the
feelings of like a sunset or a train
ride and I feel like this movie is it's
a good balance of that because I'll have
these quiet moments but then they'll
have a lot of insanity - they'll have
all these things just being thrown at
you constantly just non-stop but it
knows how to balance it out where you
can have suddenly these very simple
moments or he's very quiet moments they
can have characters are very very scary
and the characters are very very kind
and charming
but there is definitely kind of this
intimidation going through the majority
of it that I think is what keeps a kid
invested I think is what keeps an adult
invested
well there has to be that element of
like you could die at any moment or you
could get found out or you can get
caught or use something terrible could
happen to you
and I think you need them that's why I
think you need that fear in of kids
movies still I think that's sort of the
investment and I think it also helps in
developing them you know sort grow up
and see that you know you can tackle
these things you can get through these
things that's very much what this movie
is it's a little kid trying to get
through these really tough insane
moments in this tough insane world when
at the beginning she was just afraid of
moving to a new place or she just didn't
want to go see anything and she was kind
of a whiny little kid and you see her
just get through all this stuff and it's
just so masterfully done the music is
incredible the characters are incredible
the animation phenomenal I mean just
friggin phenomenal all these creatures I
mean any one of them you could just take
out and you can look at and analyze just
look at the way this thing looks I mean
how long did it take them to design this
thing it's just any of the characters
you could do that any of these creatures
and it's just phenomenal it's I don't
even know what else to say about I don't
even know what else I can say about it
cuz everybody said it already I mean
it's just this amazing movie and more
and more people you know will show it to
their kids and scare the shit out of
them but they'll also kind of liked
being scared you know I me this is like
a kids like to go to haunted houses they
like horror movies too and stuff and I
think this is kind of a good
introduction to that while also being
very charming and very interesting and
very creative and very whimsical it's
just a whimsical movie it's a magical
whimsical movie um my thing if
somebody's just gonna take me to a new
world I mean a place I haven't been
before and I'm both excited and
terrified of it at the same time it's
like this is that movie and it's just ah
love it just love it love it love it so
much uh I came to think about what else
to say about just so perfect such a
perfect film so guys that's about it
next week I will do an artist outage
Craig
right back on track and I hope you
enjoyed this list and I will see you
later
take care